so let's begin have everybody ready
everybody ready let's go
all right we are almost 1600.
we're moving right along and 1620 lozax
okay let's go e4
[Music]
let's go with the vienna gimbal maybe
what should we play i don't know let's
play
ray lopez italian scotch
okay let's play vn again but let's play
a vienna gamble let's go knight c3
let's play avayana gambit
and f4 that's my volley on the gambit
because most people okay d6 now this is
a very common move at this level it's
not terrible but it's very passive
it's very passive um it's a
typical way of declining the gambit it
blocks in the bishop and it essentially
gives us all that we want now in the
vienna your goal
is for black to take the pawn what does
it do why are we sacrificing the pawn
well there are two main reasons the
first is that we of course get
uh a bigger control of the center with
d4 the second is that we open up the f
file
and as i've often stated opening up the
f file is a double-sided sword on the
one hand
it can be good for black because well
it's a weakness particularly of white
castle short
but it can also be a great strength
because white's rook on f1
will have essentially a wide open avenue
to attacking blacks upon an f7 if that
makes sense
so how should we play here well there's
nothing particularly special that we
should do we should just develop our
pieces and try to get black to take the
pun
yeah with the vienna you play knight c3
i'll talk about that a little bit after
the game
okay knight c6 and now we we have two
choices for where to develop this bishop
we can um we can develop it to c4 but we
can also play the sort of rye lopez
style
and and develop it to b5 and the plus of
developing
developing it to b5 is that we put
immediate pressure on the pawn on e5
i've analyzed this a little bit
because i have some students who play
the vienna and bishop v5 is the best
move i think this should be five
this is like a rye lopez on steroids
though bishop d7
all right now what should we do
this is a bit of a trick question
because i think i know what some of you
will come up with
what do you think we should do yeah so
dj you fell into my trap
now some of you may think ah let me take
the knight and then take the pawn and
win a pawn
but you need to see the bigger picture
here which is that
white isn't very well developed yet and
going after the pawn not only does it
not win a pawn because black will be
able to capture on e4 i'll show this
after the game
but those transformations are favorable
for black because whites we've made a
weakness on the king side and so
the point of the vienna isn't to go upon
hunting it's to develop your pieces and
go for an attack
now i would consider this a little bit
more carefully but it still doesn't work
still doesn't work who can tell me why
if we take on c6
and then we take twice on e5 what move
is black going to have at the end of the
line which shows the fact that the f
file being open is double-sided
you know not bishop takes e4
bishop takes c4 is not dangerous but
queen d4 chuck
forks the knight and the king so instead
of this we should move our bishop where
should we move it
we can move it either to c4 or to a4 i
feel like
now that we've castled bishop c4 makes
more sense
maybe a sacrifice on f7 is on the cards
let's go bishop c4
if he doesn't do anything to castle if
he doesn't go here
okay goes bishop e6 that's not a
terrible move
now what options do we have we can
either trade bishops that's probably
what we're going to end up doing because
that weakens the center and it's king
side
or if we wanted to trade on our own
terms if we wanted to make a mature move
how could we trade on our own terms
what's the common move in such positions
it's not d3 it's bishop b3 bishop b3
stepping back you see this in the london
you see this in a lot of different
openings
i call it trading on your own terms
where you get black to take your bishop
you take with the a pawn
and it's a much more favorable
transformation than for example playing
d3 but
i like the concept of taking the bishop
because we weaken his position
nothing wrong with that at all simple
chess now
again we can play more positionally we
can play more tactically
um the positional move is to take on e5
we can take on e5 and just say okay
you're gonna have double pawns you're
gonna have weak pawns in the center
and then we can play d3 and bishop g5
and we have a slight advantage
but we can also play this very
aggressively very tactically
and how should we play it tactically if
we wanted to well
he has an e-pawn that's now a weakness
we need to consider that
can we attack it let's go ahead and do
it knight you five
probably not what i would have played in
one of my own games
but it is in the spirit of the vienna
yeah d3 is fine too d3 is a more
positional move
but i want to act with a sense of
urgency here
all right now we have a really cool idea
which let me calculate one moment i'm
just trying to figure it out whether it
works
it's believe it or not it's very complex
there's an idea that that that is
very interesting
but it's but it's it's it involves a
certain degree of risk
but let's do it now it's yeah so you
guys are many of you are saying
d f takes e5 and if he takes with a
knight then he walks right into d4
if he takes with a pawn many of you are
noticing the possibility of bringing the
queen out to h5 but of course that's not
possible when he has an i don't have six
so
as i'll show after the game we could
have sacrificed our exchange here
doing the same thing isn't effective
because that knight could step back to
g6 and block the check so here of course
we should just play d4
uh with tempo this is a phenomenal
position for us knight g6
so what should we do now how should we
transform
our clear initiative into a concrete
advantage
now what we need to realize here is that
when you've got a center like this when
you've got an attack on the pawn
you just need the move i think flows
naturally from the position
there's two pawn breaks that need to be
considered there's e5 and d5
if you look at e5 carefully you'll see
that after d takes e5 that just gives a
pawn up
i don't see a follow up there and that
allows the queen trade which is not in
our favor
but the move d5 is very good because it
establishes a stronghold for the knight
on e6
that's a more positional move than
anything uh but that outpost 96 is going
to be completely deadly
very natural play
after he okay it was e5 our move is
very obvious now we go knight e6 look at
this beautiful outpost he can't even
castle
he can barely move this knight paralyzes
his entire position
and it's supported by a pawn chain so
even if he goes c6
we don't need to do anything about that
because our pawn
will not be at risk of being undermined
yeah so as gaines is indicating bishop
g5 is probably going to be our follow-up
hitting the knight on f6 his position is
on the verge of collapse if he goes
bishop b7 he drops the pawn there comes
c6
here comes c6 we don't need to do
anything about it he's not
really threatening to take that will
soften up our knight outpost
but it won't necessarily you know won't
do anything specific by the time he gets
around to challenging this knight is
going to be checkmated
bishop g5 it is now in such situations
you know that the very best players when
you get into a situation you can feel
that the win
is nearby you don't want to rush a
single move because you never know when
there might be a hidden tactic or a way
to improve on the obvious move so e
takes d5 is the obvious move and it's
perfectly good enough
is there a better move is there any way
to win the game even faster there
is if you take on f6 he can take the
other knight
but the best move is knight takes d5 he
takes on e6 not hard to establish
that we fork the queen and the king
which is what's going to happen and i'll
show what have happened yeah he resigns
if he would have taken our knight then
in contrast with the immediate e takes
d5 in contrast with this
the f file is open the f file being open
is obviously in our favor
he's totally paralyzed we have a very
simple plan of victory we can go queen
h5 or
queen f3 i mean there's just every
anything would win here he's he can
resign
all right
so that was a nice game and the vienna
is one of the best
openings bar none for players of this
level 1600 1700.
so the bottom line in the vienna is that
e takes f4 is a big mistake
a lot of people take the pawn thinking
that this is a king's gambit
but the difference between the king's
gamut and the vienna is revealed in the
fact that the knights are developed
which is in white's favor
because the move e5 becomes possible
chasing away the knight
in fact the knight has nowhere to go it
has to go back to g8 which is a huge
undeveloper pieces like this is not good
you go knight f3 don't go d4
don't allow this nasty check on h4 so
you go knight f3 then d4 you've got a
big lead in development you're probably
going to win this pawn back
i've got a couple of students who play
this black is in massive trouble here
now there's a couple of beautiful lines
that stem from
this position one is well black often
plays d6
right and you play d4 to support the
pawn
after d takes c5 i've analyzed this very
deeply with a computer
and it may appear that white is in a
little bit of trouble here because if
you take with a knight
what move is possible i just want to
hammer this into people's heads
this is a big no-no in such positions
because it allows but h4 check
why is this a problem because you have
to move your king if you go g3
then there's f takes g3 the pawn on f4
is a very nasty one
but if you play d e then you allow the
queen trading you certainly don't want
to allow the queen trade the whole point
of a development advantage is to
well you don't want the queen trade so
you give a check on b5 you develop a
tempo
but black simply has the move c6 so what
are we doing here
but the funny thing is you just play
bishop c4 you have three pieces
developed
black is none and you don't give a damn
about any of the pawns e takes d4
um and at this point wait just let me
remember
yeah at this point you play bishop takes
f4
that's the idea okay now you're
currently two pawns down
currently two pawns down what do you
have in a turn for them you've developed
all four pieces and black's developed
nothing now what are we doing here why
are we giving away the knight what's the
idea
what's the idea here and this is an idea
which we've had on the speed run many
times
the king in contact with the queen boom
goes the dynamite but
it's not over yet black has the move
king e7 he doesn't have to take the
bishop and drop the queen
now we sacrifice another piece we give a
check on e2
this forces the king to take the bishop
but now the king is literally toast
and there's one really funny line
um you have several ways to win the game
several ways to win the game let me
remember
what the best line is i'm trying to
remember
yeah so the best move here is knight to
e5
check centralizing the knight if the
king goes back to ea
then it walks right into a discovered
check which wins the queen
all right this is a typical discovered
check wins the queen black will have
some pieces for the queen but because
black's king is so exposed he's still
losing
so the king can go to e6 and you still
have a discovery
all right so king f6 seems to be the
only way to avoid losing a queen
immediately but what tactic does white
have in this position
and this is another very common pattern
bishop g5 distracting
knight f7 check winning the queen but
you don't even take the queen
yet if black ghost king f6 white has a
really sexy move
really sexy move you don't have to take
the queen yet
what is that sexy move this this move
will get you way too many dates
castle will check depend on the night
black has to block it with bishop f5
rook takes f5 this all plays itself rock
f1
king g6 and checkmate is at hand after
queen g4
yeah this is mate that's a really sick
line
so black is forced to go king g6 and now
comes an even cooler to me this is even
cooler
now you can take the queen that seems
very natural and that is winning
but it's not winning as obviously as
people may think because remember black
has three pieces for the queen
and if black brings all of his pieces
out the king may become relatively safe
so instead of taking the queen what else
can white do here this move
looks really bad you can take the rook
now it looks bad because why would you
take the rook when you can take the
queen
but the point is that the king has
nowhere to go
if it goes to h6 or g5 you simply return
to f7 and win the queen if it goes to f6
we already know
how white wins white castles bishop f5
is forced
king has no other squares the fact that
the queen cuts the king off is what
kills black
and then you basically do the same thing
it's a slightly different checkmate
after king g5 you do basically transpose
into
the main line queen g4 with checkmate
you don't even have to take the queen
it's yeah this is uh what i analyzed so
this is really amazing now this is
unlikely to happen
in all of your games but it's just one
example of how tactical the vienna can
get and
the consequences you suffer if you're
behind in development
you're welcome so i hope everybody
followed more or less the lens
uh which this is why he takes f4 as a
mistake
the the best move is d5 the best move is
d5
um and that counter strikes in the
center it's a pretty logical move right
you meet a
move on the flank with a move in the
center and this is the theoretical
position where queen f3 has recently
become
uh the best move this is super
interesting i think levi's met of course
on this i don't want to get into the
details
but it's quite dangerous it's quite a
dangerous line for black
so black i've even faced it myself and
i've lost a couple of games here with
black
i highly recommend the vienna for people
who want this kind of stuff
okay so there is no
really good way and technically this
declines the gambit technically this is
a counter gambit almost
but material is equal so d6 is not
terrible
but it's the precursor to playing very
passively so knight c6 is fine bishop b5
this is all okay for him but i think he
has to develop very quickly he's got to
go bishop b7 and castle
clearly black is worse here um from a
just positional perspective but black's
position is very solid here there's
nothing terribly wrong with playing this
all right and and how should white play
here why does a couple of ways of going
about this maybe it's time to take on e5
another good move is to talk the king on
h1 so that these queen d4 check ideas
i'm sure you've seen this move played in
many types of positions it's kind of the
same as going king b1 when you're
castling long
the vienna is not a no vienna is played
by many grandmasters it's not unsound at
all i mean black can equalize on the
main line but white is not worse
white is not worse in the main line even
if black plays everything correctly
what are the reasons why it is clearly
better positionally well if you can
compare the development right
look at how passive black's bishops are
white's bishop light squared bishop is
developed to a good square knights are
developed to good squares
white's got more central control than
black white's got these two puns
white can bring a third pawn up it's
just even visually
it has to do with the fact that black is
very passive black's pieces don't have a
lot of potential energy and white's
pieces have a lot
all right so he plays a6 we play bishop
c4 again
why didn't we take on c6 takes takes
f takes d takes knight takes this is a
very bad move
because we've castled black hasn't
castled it should be clear to you guys
that
black is gonna get killed here i mean
knight takes f7 for one thing
looks pretty good and despite this check
i think black is on the cusp of being
losing
another little side note there is no
smothered mate when you've got a rook on
f1
this is a very good way to defend
against mother may because you can
always sack the exchange in this
position
you're not actually attacking the
exchange here because blackstroke is
also hanging
but that's the bottom line
and but but but all of that is a moot
point because queen d4 check wins the
knight
so that's a pretty big uh
pretty pretty typical kind of blunder
when you open the f file
all right bishop c4 um
it well gdd it's it's played by gm's
it's played by jim
but but yeah at the highest level
everybody knows how to equalize
it's not particularly testing at the
highest level because everybody knows
how to equalize
but again white is not worse okay
um so bishop e6 we decided to take the
bishop
i still think he should have gone bishop
e7 and castled it wouldn't have been too
late although now
black is quite a bit worse so bishop c4
bishop b6
captures captures and again
the positional approach would be to
simply take and say yeah you've got
these doubled pawns they're also
isolated
so we just go d3 bishop c5 king h1 but
this is a little boring white is better
undoubtedly white is better then you
have a plan for example of getting your
queen to g3
but we decided to play a little bit more
adventurously knight to g5
now i think that black had a better way
perhaps
of defending this pawn there was knight
knight to d4
which would have been quite interesting
but our opponent played queen d7 we go f
takes c5
and at this point knight takes c5 is i
would say a decisive mistake
because allowing this move to be played
with tempo is
is totally disastrous totally totally
disastrous
um but after dtak c5 i was calculating a
very cool continuation rook takes f6
now the idea is to remove the defender
from the h5 square
this line is very simple to calculate if
king to d8
you give a four can you win the rook if
king to e7
who can spot the winning continuation
and it's not just the first move you
need to play the first move correctly
and the second move is very important
not to fall for the temptation
look carefully guys everybody should be
able to see this move
queen f7 but this is the tricky moment
a lot of you guys are falling for the
temptation to take i know it
don't make any assumptions about what
the correct move looks like
king c8 and black is out of the woods
the knight check looks
fancy but it doesn't do anything the
move you have to play is this check
queen f6
this does something this forks the rook
and the king and white wins the rook and
wipes up a piece
all right queen takes f6 very important
the move all doesn't always look good
but this is the move which accomplishes
the most but
what was i calculating what did i spend
time calculating this took me a couple
of seconds
what about king d6 oh you're right yeah
i mean king d6 is possible
but after queen takes f6 anyway there's
going to be too many threats
you're right that should be considered
but knight f7 is going to come and the
king is going to get hunted down
all right oh my goodness there's a cool
line there
yeah i miss king d6 but i think white is
winning here anyway
but great great job indicating this you
know what would be a nice movers b3
could be cool too
preparing bishop a3 and black can't
really take because of the fork
that's kind of cool anyways um
so what was i looking at what was i
looking at
what was i worried about
again when you play the vienna you
always have to watch for stuff happening
on this diagonal
because that's that's the price you pay
to get such a tactical position
bishop c5 check is an intermediate move
which can be potentially very very nasty
well queen d4 doesn't do much queen d4
you can play rook f2
queen d4 you can play rook f2 and you're
fine but you can even go king h1
and i don't think this is any weaker
because the queen is now
away from d7 but um
rook f2 check just keeps the extra piece
and after bishop c5 white has to be a
little bit careful but
i don't think white's in any trouble for
one thing you could play the move queen
to f3
and if you count up the material after
black takes everything white's got two
pieces for a rook
white's much much better here that's a
pretty significant material plus
but black can play bishop c5 first
and if king h1 then g takes f6 and if
queen h5 the king now has this little
square on f8
uh where it can go to and it seems to be
relatively safe
but there is the move in this position
rook f2
anyway and that's a hard move to spot it
looks very scary right you have to get
your king to f2
but i couldn't find anything any good
follow-up for black or for cafe travel i
could even castle with check
just drop your knife back to f3 if queen
d4
check the king can migrate to g3 which i
think is a
very safe square there's just no stuff
on the king side that black could use
to attack the game as soon as white
plays d3 and gets the bishop out this is
called consolidating
white's going to be totally fine two
pieces for rook white is better
all right but in such situations you've
got to look for the intermediate mode
it's always easy for me to say but
practice telling yourself that you're
going to see more of these kinds of
moves
just like in the background after knight
takes c5 d4 and i26
and now d5 d5 securing the e6 square for
the night
this is game over um
e5 96 yeah this is totally crushing he's
got no moves if he moves the bishop out
the knight takes g7
but the way it happened yeah this and a
fork
um just last thing
after king f7 96 who can spot the
fastest way to win the game
what's the fastest way to follow up from
here and force
uh just a complete catastrophe
boom boom simple clearance of the
defender
removal the defender check check i won
the rook
yeah and the game is over red or over as
mr wrench says okay
um any questions
who invented the vienna vladimir vienna
what's the meaning of life there we go
in the mean line vienna with queen f6
yeah knight c6 is the main line
yeah the beginning of the vienna e45
knight c3
so in contrast to the kings gamble where
you play for immediately you go knight
at night c3 for don't go knight f3
that blocks the f1 knight f6 and then f4
[Music]
you